good morning Hank it's Thursday special
surprise bonus videos so I have written
a book that feels good to say also a
little terrifying
it's called turtles all the way down it
comes out on October 10th and it is
available for pre-order now in gonna do
we do below my previous book The Fault
in Our Stars came out more than five and
a half years ago so this book has
definitely been a long and winding road
but I am so excited to share it with you
I don't want to say too much about the
plot of the book but it's a story about
a young woman who's trying to solve a
mystery while also trying to live with
mental illness and in that sense well
it's definitely a made-up story it's
also kind of a personal one because as
most of you know I have a mental illness
that at times has taken over my life so
okay I think that's all the relevant
information for right now title
publication date available for pre-order
one sentence of extremely vague
introduction I'm so happy to be finished
with the book that I'm proud of I really
hope you like it also I just want to say
a quick word of thanks a lot of people
have been really patient with me and
kind over the last five and a half years
especially my family so thank you
I have often worried that I would never
publish another book and without their
support I wouldn't be now I know many of
you will have questions please leave
them in comments below and I will try to
answer some in next Tuesday's video
which by the way is going to be an
unboxing video because I hear those are
popular on YouTube Hank I will see you
tomorrow that's another thing I haven't
gotten to say for a while